[Music]  the whole world is mourning  grieving over a symbol that's hopefully  not too late it's like they were freedom  fly son it's time i  [Music]  you will help them accomplish wonders  [Music]  they wanted me back for a reason  i need to find out why  [Music]  [Music]  um  [Music]  the bells didn't rub  but in the dark  among the stars  [Music]  the god is dead  i had a dream  almost like a premonition  i think there's an attack coming  [Music]  i need warriors i'm building an alliance  to defend ourselves  how do you know your team's strong  enough  if you can't bring down the charging  bull then don't wave the red cape at it  you're sitting here for a reason  and even if it takes you the rest of  real life  find out what that reason is  [Music]  [Applause]  they said the age of heroes would never  come again  it will it has to  we live in a society where honor  is a distant memory isn't that right  [Music]  batman  [Music]  you